When I was a kid, I used to
watch the Academy Awards
every single year.
And so I never, ever thought
I would win an Academy Award.
Just having a moment like this,
being here at the Oscars.
That is magical.
So I'd say to my younger self,
“A ll the stories you have to tell,
try and tell them, because
they're the best ones.”
You know,I mean
I started a long time ago
when I started projecting
Mack Sennett pictures
against the wall of my bedroom.
I’ve been Questlove for 30 years.
And if you could tell the person
that used to busk for change
on South Street in Philadelphia
where his life is headed,
wow.
Well my daughter has grown up
and she saw me as her father
always being busy performing on
stage at all these various theaters,
and she was trying to understand
what her father was doing.
But I think finally now she's able
to witness this and come along
in my journey and come along
on this wild ride with me.
Hey!
(laughing)
We’re so proud of you.
Thanks. Thanks.
This is cool, right?
How does it feel Aneil?
Nice.
This feels nice.
Yeah.
That's how I describe it.
That is the joy of living
is experiencing,
new, surprising aspects of life.
And that's what this is.
Just believe
in your dreams.
Carry on. Do it.
Make mistakes.
Learn from your mistakes.
And don't stop doing it.
When I came here
to this country,
I had an Oscar that I borrowed
that I put in my office.
And I was really looking at it
every day and saying,
“Maybe one day
I'd be lucky to get one.”
One key thing is
to never give up.
Never give up for your dreams.